opposition leader alexis navalny
supporters have been protesting for
weeks
with thousands arrested across the
country on wednesday
police turned their attention to his
friends and family
russian police raided navalny's moscow
apartment and detained his brother oleg
they also raided the apartment where his
wife lives
they broke my door in and they're not
letting in my lawyer
we see that a series of raids on members
of the anti-corruption foundation were
launched today
it's a clear and prejudiced violation of
the right of defense
as a lawyer i consider that julia's
rights are violated
as well as rights of those who are
deprived of lawyers
alexei navalny's personal doctor was
also a target
anastasia vasilyeva continued to play
the piano
as police raided her home
anti-kremlin's sentiment has rarely been
this public during president vladimir
putin's time in power
navalny analysts say will be looking to
make the most of it
is to prepare for a situation when he
and the main opposition leader can
become a real contender for power
in washington president joe biden's new
secretary of state
was straightforward in his assessment as
i say we have a deep concern
for mr navalny's safety and uh and
security
uh and and the larger point is that uh
his voice is the voice of many many many
russians
and uh it uh should be heard not uh not
muzzled
russia's political opposition is likely
to face tougher resistance
if anti-government protests keep pace
but with a new president in the white
house
they have a powerful new ally on the
global stage
zayn basravi al-jazeera